I would like to talk to you about
business the thing that everyone on
Shark Tank thinks they have a great idea
for even this guy our cakes are made of
foam and they're rentals wait so I can
neither have my cake nor eat it - I am
in here is a million dollars small
startup businesses like that hold a
special place in America's heart and
politicians from across the political
spectrum love to talk about how
important they are small business is the
backbone of the American economy the
backbone of our economy is that rare
thing that every politician agrees on
it's that support the troops Ted Cruz
can go himself
and South Dakota Senator John Thune can
get it he can get it it can feel like an
adult an age of small business startups
but that isn't actually the case the
rate at which new businesses are being
created has actually been steadily
falling since the 1970s and I would
argue that one of the reasons for that
is that big businesses have been getting
even bigger which brings us to our main
topic tonight corporate consolidation
recent years have seen record highs for
mergers and acquisitions as you would
know if you've ever watched the thrilled
reactions they get on business news M&A
has been hot continues to be hot an
exciting year for M&A a few blockbuster
deals being announced they call it
merger Monday on Wall Street is shaping
up to be another merger Monday they
don't call it merger Monday it for
nothing media mega merger one big mug
merger Monday at last we have one and I
say
[Music]
okay that is obviously a little
nauseating but also pressing a button on
TV is a little bit dangerous because
someone could take that footage and then
loop any sound that they want under
there now obviously I am NOT immature
enough to do that but if I were it would
look like this merger Monday at last we
have one and I say
[Music]
Forte's appointees all this merger
activity has helped make some sectors of
our economy ridiculously consolidated
the United States has gone from having
ten large Airlines back in 2002 just for
today and those four mega Airlines now
dominate more than 80 percent of the US
market yeah we're down to just four
major airline choices and no that does
not include JetBlue because that is not
actually an airline it's just a very
expensive way to eat those weird blue
chips which are and this is true just
slice to Grover arms and Airlines here
are just the beginning at the rental car
business is now 90 percent dominated by
just three companies at the u.s. beer
industry is 70% controlled by just two
companies and online search engines are
of course as we all know dominated by
one major player that's right say it
with me big that's right
Bing the best way to Google something in
fact Clovis ganja here even our own
parent company Time Warner is currently
trying to merge with AT&T which makes
this story a little dangerous for us to
do well you know that is presuming that
AT&T executives managed to get their
shitty service working long enough to
see it ATM team it's the top telecom
company around alphabetically and
nothing else even sometimes you might
think of as indie now have multinational
owners Burt's Bees it's it's not run by
a backwards B called Burt
it's run by Clorox tom's of Maine the
deodorant which did so little to
deodorize your freshman year roommate
that's now owned by Colgate Palmolive
and then there is Goose Island now their
ads feature beardy Brewers rubbing hops
on their faces but what they don't
mention is that Goose Island is owned by
anheuser-busch and that farm that you
just saw is located at 8:22 but what is
a loop it presumably just past Bud
Lights Lima Rita boulevards basically if
you see the mass grave of Clydesdale
horses turn left and you're there
and it says something about the rapid
rate of mergers that even Jim Cramer
occasionally finds himself in disbelief
at one happening watch him react to a
mega merger in the aluminum can industry
ball Corpse were a position of rack Sam
is taking the number of competitors in
this space down to get this from three
to two yeah it's not great when they
business casual louis c.k with a sound
effects board is saying holy this
was a really bad idea but but how did
they let that happen is actually a
really good question and the answer is
interesting because we have had
antitrust laws on the books for more
than a century and I'm not saying that
every single merger is bad sometimes
business is getting bigger can lead to
greater efficiencies and improvements
the tension is between allowing that and
preventing them from doing real harm so
it's a it's a balance but since the late
1970s that balance has tipped decidedly
in favor of being merger friendly which
has led to real problems and let's start
with the obvious for workers mergers can
often mean big layoffs but it's not just
employees that can suffer consumers can
too as Jim Cramer explained in that
aluminum can segment in an inexplicably
sarcastic tone of voice I always say
competition while great for you or
consumer is an enactment of profits
sometimes a business will be a total
monopoly with no competition whatsoever
and while that's the idea what's very
rare to see a genuine monopoly because
of course it's against the law which
brings us to the next best thing an
oligopoly where a handful of companies
control an entire industry coexisting
peacefully without much in the way of
price competition that's a weird tone to
use to describe something that's clearly
awful it's rare to see genuine
bestiality because of course it's
against the law which brings us to the
next best thing having sex with a
stuffed animal about looking at pictures
of a real
and and for a sense of what it can look
like when a handful of companies coexist
peacefully without much in the way a
Prost competition just look at Airlines
in 2012 one airline executive told an
industry conference consolidation has
allowed us to do things like ancillary
revenues which is jargon for all those
fees that drive you crazy now
American was the first major airline to
charge you for your first checked bag
back in 2008 and back then people could
not believe it
American Airlines will soon charge
fifteen dollars for the first checked
bag that's on top of a fee of $25 for
your second one fifteen dollars holy cow
I'll have to put my underwear in my
package yes first that is clearly a
delightful man although it does make you
wonder whether he fills his bags full of
underwear and nothing else but but
within months most major airlines had
followed Americans lead and it was
essentially the industry standard and it
is easy for that to happen when there's
only a handful of big players in fact
since then they've added an increased
bag fees multiple times often moving in
tandem which is how those fees have gone
from generating around 540 million
dollars a year a decade ago to 4.2
billion dollars now and that is
infuriating after all if I wanted
exorbitant fees that keep getting raised
all the time despite shitty service I've
become a customer of AT&T
[Applause]
and you you may well be angry with the
service you get from Airlines but thanks
to consolidation they don't really need
to give a about what you think and
if you don't believe me remember that
awful video that went around earlier
this year the shocking images of a
passenger caught in a travel nightmare
a man visibly shaken as he's yanked and
then dragged off a United jet by law
enforcement all after refusing to give
up his seat yeah that is the most
horrifying thing you can possibly see on
an airplane unless your in-flight movie
is the boss baby a movie that combines
the unbearable smugness of Alec Baldwin
with the unbearable smugness of the baby
now in the wake of that incident people
said it was a PR nightmare and there was
talk on Twitter of boycotting United the
problem is on certain routes they're the
only option so a boycott is going to be
pretty hard to pull off and that is
arguably why their CEO was like too able
to open his earnings call for that
quarter by describing a period in which
I will remind you a passenger had his
teeth knocked out on one of United's
planes like this
welcome to a terrific second quarter
strong financial results and even more
incredible operational results and as
you think about customers I want to
thank them for their continued loyalty
and support we continue to find new and
better ways service and more comfortable
and you know what is it really any
wonder that their earnings stayed solid
United is sometimes the only way to get
to where you are going which actually
explains their new slogan you want a
rollerblade to Houston shut up
and get in
and when an industry gets too
consolidated any company trying to
compete with them or survive in their
supply chain can get crushed now we all
know about Amazon Walmart or Google but
there are less obvious examples of this
to take eyewear now if you go into a
LensCrafters
you will see frames by brands like Prada
Dolce & Gabbana Burberry and Ralph
Lauren all of which it turns out are
made by an italian company called
luxottica which incidentally also owns
LensCrafters
and sunglass hut and pearl vision and
runs target optical and Sears Optical so
what can happen when a smaller company
goes up against them we'll just ask
Oakley Oakley was a big competitor and
they had a fight with luxottica and
luxottica basically said we're dropping
you from our stores and we used to sell
there at glasses and it was a dispute
about pricing and they dropped Oakley
from the stores and Oakley stock price
collapsed there were some issues between
the two companies in the beginning of
the 2000s but both of them understood
that it was better to go along we merged
with Oakley in 2007 but are talking they
tried to compete and they lost and then
you bought them I understand your theory
but then restore that life was better
together that is the menacing tone of a
Bond villain
they understood life was better together
that is the first time that I've ever
felt sorry for Oakley the official
sunglasses of guys who own ironically
use the term finger-blasting and I think
it's a sponsorship deal and and there is
one more victim of consolidation that
you may not think about and that is the
products themselves because heavily
consolidated industries can lose the
incentive to innovate and the best
example of this may be the cable box
beneath your TV if you have one of those
you probably hate it because it's huge
it's glitchy and it may be one of the
largest energy consuming items in your
house even when it's turned off but if
you think about it cable companies have
no real incentive to improve them
they're essentially regional regional
monopolies and again they know that you
basically have nowhere else to go and
you can't even smash your cable box out
of frustration because you are renting
it and they'll then charge you hundreds
of dollars if you don't give it back
which is why we went to the trouble of
blowing this one up for you please take
a look there you go pretty cathartic to
watch right feel free to watch it again
in slow motion
[Applause]
[Music]
I want you to know that box suffered the
point here is we seem to have forgotten
how important antitrust is and now all
being forced to live with the
consequences because this issue affects
almost everything you do angry at banks
or the industry is dominated by just
these four frustrated with your health
insurance provider odds are it's one of
these and if this whole story is
infuriating you so much that you are
yearning for the Sweet Escape of death
well bad luck because the casket
industry is controlled by these three
companies oh and it gets even worse the
afterlife is actually controlled by one
religion I am NOT saying which one but
when you find out you're going to be so
mad we have laws to prevent the worst
effects of consolidation and it may well
be time to more aggressively use them to
impose stricter standards and to empower
the FTC and the DOJ x' antitrust
divisions and that is something that
most people would really get behind and
nearly every politician should after all
there is one thing they cannot stop
saying well if they really believe that
it may be time for them to stop talking
about backbones and actually
grow on this and now all of Jim Cramer's
sound buttons replaced with fart noises
hedge funds that are in trouble start
selling not because they want to but
because they have to raise money to pay
back their unhappy clients
things keep working ow
is it any wonder that Norfolk Southern
Union Pacific keep running
by hi and then sell low a time-honored
way to lose money sell it tomorrow
because the whole idea of saving for
retirement puts you to sleep but I want
you to feel emboldened not as we tell
you what we would do before we pull any
trigger I was wrong on both camps
[Music]